[موسيقى]
القبض على الرئيس صدام حسين يوم 12 وتم
عرضه يوم 13
موضوع يعني اللي يشيع انه ضربه المنطقه
بالغازات المنومه موضوع ما لا اصل ولا لا
صحه
نقل الي من محافظ صلاح الدين
الله يرحمها
لواء عبد الله جباره اكد لي انه من خلال
القوات الامريكيه
احد القاده تحدثنا والقائد هذا يشارك
بعمليه الاعتقال اللي يسموه الامريكان
الفجر الاحمر عم احمر
يقول بعد ان تم القاء القبض على الرئيس
يعني من المكان اللي كان فيه وهو ملجا
يعني محصن ضد القصف
الرئيس ما قبل يصعد يعني ويا الامريكان
بالطائره البلاكوك يقول فنادوا على المفرز
الطبيه
وحقنوه ابره مخدره يعني ماده مخدره
وصعد وياهم
طبعا معلومه لازم يعني اوضحها للمشاهد
الكريم انه الرئيس سبق وان تمت مداهمه هذا
المكان مرتين قبل هاي المداهمه والرئيس
كان في نفس نفس المكان ونجى يعني نجح من
الاعتقال لكن هذا هذه المره لانه كانت
وشايه
تم القاء القبر هي حقيقه خدروا خدروا
القوات الامريكيه
ولكنه لم ينقل خارج العراق
اختلفت بعض الروايات اللي يشكك ان وجوده
لا نقل الى احد القواعد القواعد العسكريه
الامريكيه خارج العراق
وبعد ما كنا نقابله لما كنت اقابله بيوم
اللي اخبر الجانب الامريكي يعني اطلب منهم
تحريريا عن طريق الايميل والعنوان اللي
اعطوني اياه
بعدها بسبعه ايام الله تيجي الموافقه فكان
الشك انه اذا موجود داخل العراق ماكو داعي
لهاي المده طويله
المعلومات لاحقا على ما يعني في مؤخرا
يعني في السنوات الاخيره لانه في معلومات
بكتابك عن اللي قالوا هو شخصيا لك تختلف
عن هذا عما تقول الان نعم بخصوص تخدير
وبخصوص نقله الى خارج العراق يبدو من خلال
حديثه معك كان متاكد من انه هو لم يخدر
ولم ينقل الى هو الدليل بيوم اللي طلعه
يوم 13 عرضوه يعني كان زيغان
الزوغان العينين واضح جدا مخدر يعني كان
الوضع وضع غير طبيعي وحتى يعني وسائل
اعلام يعني اجنبيه اكدت انه كان مخدر واضح
جدا كان لم يذكر لك شيء عن هذا الموضوع عن
نقله الى الخارج نقله ما كان يعرف ما كان
يعرف لانه لاحقا فيما بعد يعني من كنت
اجلس وياه ونقلت لاحد الاطباء العراقيين
مقيم في السويد انه قال لي اوصف لي وضعه
قلت له كان ترجف قال لي ايده اليمنى غير
ايده الاسرائيلي ايده اليسرى معناته اكو
خلل يعني يتعلق
بالقلبنى يعني معناته كان يعني يعطى سموم
وبطريقه بطيئه جدا وكان هذا المتوقع لانه
منزوفيتش تم تسميمه
الرئيس يعني كان يبعث رسائل لاسرته
فتحرينا على هالموضوع انه كانت الرسائل
تسحب منه بدون علمه يعني كان يخليها بجيبه
ويعطى عصير قبل يوم او بنفس
يعني قبل زيارته له بساعات يعطى عصير ويتم
اخذ التقاط الرسائل دون علمه